now we are a part of a society that has
changed
you can't really Force things to go
backwards otherwise you end up in a sort
of authoritarian state right you like
you have to get married you have to do
this you have to have kids there is no
other you can you can you certainly
can't yeah
I'm not saying very well I don't think
that's a fair comparison no fault
divorce was legal like 50 years ago it
wasn't that long ago it's not even I
think it was the 90s so that's like what
30 years ago it wasn't even that long
ago well she's absolutely right you
can't force
um things on human beings what would
happen is we would eventually kill
ourselves off that's what is going to
happen so you can't force us to go back
to the way things were what will happen
is naturally we will take ourselves back
to the bottom and reset I think the
problem is when you look at the policies
whether they're like negative policies
or positive incentives none of them have
worked like when you look at all of East
Asia all of Eastern Europe now Western
Europe not a single country has managed
to get back to replacement level
population fertility not a single
country all of them have gone below
every single country in Europe is not
having enough babies to sustain the
population but that doesn't mean it
works
but I think that way in Africa too
because I thought I thought the average
number of kids in Nigeria was like five
it's still pretty high in most of
sub-Saharan Africa but it's going down
everywhere even Iran even in India India
is like almost below replacement
um and the thing is I think it's because
you know Hungary pays you goodness knows
how much to have kids like you have
three kids you get a free people carrier
stuff like that you get you know if you
have enough kids in Hungary I think it's
three or four you pay no income tax for
the rest of your life they have huge
incentives man this is crazy but they're
not really getting the birth rate back
up and the problem is not so much about
economic incentives it's fundamentally
what people think of being a parent
people in the modern world especially in
the west just don't think being a parent
is that valuable or fulfilling and I
think the key issue is that we need to
reframe Parenthood and re you know show
that it's not just a burden it's not
just our kid who's going to ruin your
life and stop you doing things
kids are valuable they're great we're
looking forward to having them like I
think that's the key issue is we have to
stop saying you know being a mother is
going to ruin your life we have to say
being a mother is an incredible thing
that you should be hugely proud of and
that you should be able to do alongside
everything else in your career in your
family and so on I think that's the key
question I think that starts with being
less critical of single women then
because it's better that they're having
kids at all right no actually women
respond really well to social pressure
so I actually think shame is a great
thing I actually think we should bring
it back I think we can have a sort of
Hope problem and propaganda so I think
we should we should propagandize women
and take away most of the Reproductive
Rights I think the birth control get rid
of divorce get rid of we can't even have
birth control no I would ban that too I
know the men are like I can't get behind
you on that Korea over here
Korea is a fair comparison
I don't think
I don't think look at I think birth
control is bad for women these women go
on birth control for 10 years it makes
us absolutely nuts then we get off of
birth control and we have fertility and
hormone issues it can be bad it's like
is this really a good outcome for us
yeah
we can't have the kids and then we get
on the antidepressants it's just like a
wholesale
it is that birth control has been proven
to be incredible I don't know that was
infertile on my show from too many plan
B's yeah she literally could not have
children from Plan B right and this is
getting pretty common as well and Helen
said that people don't want to be
parents and I think that's true of young
people but women generally want to have
kids in their life but they're now just
leaving it until they're in their 40s
and we all know that that has issues
um so encouraging women to have making
it like absolutely fine showing
influencers showing like you know
celebrities that are able to maintain a
career and also
um maintain motherhood at home and
maintain sex a successful motherhood see
I just don't think it's possible I think
there's always going to be something you
have to give because if you're working
who's watching the kids and someone else
but I think part of that is because we
need to do it together male and female
that's right we've lost the Parenthood
well we've lost that expectation of the
fact that we will find someone get
married have babies together we'll
support each other like I don't know
like when you're girls when you're
looking when you're young and you're
looking for someone to be with find a
guy who's going to support yourself as
you know flourishing in your career and
flourishing as a mother and that's gonna
be a partnership for you both yeah I
just think that's not realistic I think
that's what feminism tries to teach us
that you can have everything and I don't
think you can and I also think there's a
whole group of women that have had
nannies and like daycare raise their
children and I think there's a lot of
negative effects from that
um I I think the the message that I
personally would say I just disagree
with you slightly but I I would I would
say you you have to make your choice and
you can't have everything I think you
can have more than people often think
yeah you're a lot more than people often
think and I think of course we have to
be honest Parenthood both motherhood and
fatherhood involve sacrifice I plan on
sacrificing a lot when I have kids I'm
not going to be able to do all the
things I want to do but the point we
have to make is that yes it involves
sacrifice for both but it's so worth it
it's more than worth it because these
are kids they're gonna be way more
meaningful than anything I just wanna oh
sorry I just want to add a certain point
on the fertility statistics because
often it gets focused on all the women
are getting too old but it's a 50 50
perfect slit split split a perfect
or fertility issues men 50 women 50 when
it comes to getting pregnant
but it is true nonetheless that 50 of
women now are reaching the age of 30
without having children which is very
different and if you see the chart the
fertility fertility drops way more for
women than it does for men in older age
but like that's not even disputable yeah
besides if women have all the power then
why is it 50 50 because women have the
power in production if women choose to
have kids later their men can only have
kids later yeah
it's usually is good but there are there
are stats to show that older women who
have younger Partners tend to get
pregnant easier my mom was one of those
which is why she could always get
pregnant I guess younger sperm is
beneficial well I mean younger I was
just looking at the chart of this today
it's not the same it drops I mean men do
have fertility issues too but it drops
off way more for women with age this
isn't even like arguable is that then
because women are always picking older
Partners I don't know why that is I just
know based on biology that women are
less fertile the older they get at a at
a much more rapid rate than men well by
how rapid do you mean right because I
can actually men can still men still
sperm in their 70s 70s
some of them I'm going to send it I'm
gonna send it to Ken I just I just
tweeted this today that's why that's why
I'm positive of this besides if women
start getting younger Partners who's
going to raise the kids
because are you gonna is she gonna trap
the younger guy into becoming
responsible it depends when you're
saying younger it could just be a 31 or
two year old with a 40 year old woman
it's not specific yeah but we all know
that men reach their financial stride
from 35 upwards I'm just very curious
about something so they definitely
shouldn't be having children before that
point then
it goes back to the same thing of women
wanting everything so they want to have
the young guy but they also want him to
be able to be responsible enough to take
care of the kid or they want to have the
old guy and they want him to be or they
want to have the richest man and they
want him to be faithful to them like
they just want everybody
do you know any 82 year old women that
have had kids
I don't know what the oldest is is it
someone in her 70s I don't know no no
there's an Al Pacino just father the
child at 82. yeah you know damn well no
women are doing that I well I don't know
what the oldest woman I don't even know
what you're arguing like you know that
men do not you know that women drop off
infertility issues
I didn't say all men but I said women
have it worse the older they get is that
I mean we have a doctor here am I am I
wrong so my only comment was it's a 50
when people are dealing with you know
infertility where they're having to seek
options
because you've got a very I'm asking how
many how many people were in that study
it was a pretty big study that I I like
I mean you could probably Google it for
fertility issues I don't have the
website to mine I have some of them
written down but not all of them usually
government websites that are holding
these statistics so fertility issues
you've got to bear in mind some men and
some women just were never fertile in
the first place right we're all assuming
that everyone's fertile all of the time
it's not the case some people are
fertile longer right
I'm saying that it's not the same for
men and for women it's not the same
but at 35 a man can have a kid pretty
easily women is geriatric pregnancy my
mom this is this is okay I'm not talking
about you I'm talking about your mom I'm
sorry about 35 is if you're able to get
pregnant no no no no no but I'm saying
it's still geriatric pregnancy if you
hit 30 the numbers say if you're single
by 30 you're more likely to not have a
child than to have one as a woman but
we're already talking about
I I I I I'm saying that it is not the
same for men and for women I don't know
what you're arguing I never said it was
the same I'm saying that okay okay
so so no I'm saying that you know that
the older we get we have more fertility
issues than so do men no I said I said
we have more than men the older we get
yeah that I agree with you yeah
that's because you're brainwasher myself
at a young age men are gonna have more
issues and but then that changes over
time so men's fertility is probably
lower to big begin with but it drops off
more gradually whereas women you know if
you're right about this 50 50 split
would have more fertility at a younger
age but then it drops very rapidly after
age 35. if you put it on the screen I
can I just was looking at this today it
drops off to 35.
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna show it to
you because I've heard so many bad
stories about people that have been
pregnant after like four uh women
I've not seen no stories on guys I've
not seen any stories about bad things
can you show the screen King I'm gonna
show you this and I just want you to
accept it that's it I just want you I
just ah nothing nothing I just want you
to look at the charts
I just want to I just want you to look
at the chart I just want all right so
this is this has nothing to do anymore
wait wait wait wait wait I just want you
to say okay that's it that's it so this
is the this is the fertility chart
and this is different statistics than
what I was talking about so can we just
this is what I was talking about so do
you do you understand this yeah I was
never debating it in the first place
okay thank you as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible